democrats and the media may have spent
over four years screaming profanities at
president trump or giving him the finger
or having celebrity elites like kathy
griffin holding an effigy of the
president's severed head but now that
trump isn't in office democrats decided
now is the time to be the party of
civility
since something far worse is now here
i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well
merry christmas and let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree
if you ask the media elites let's go
brandon isn't just a dig at the
president of the united states it's much
more dangerous than that
the asymmetry of saying
fu to a sitting president on a call in
front of your four kids
don't
look past this don't look at this as a
story about giving air time to a maggot
guy
this is the slow motion insurrection
let's go brandon isn't about what you
feel about supply chain issues and gas
it is the cry of insurrectionists it is
the cry of people who want to violently
take over this country and oppress
anyone who is not like them
seems like the media's new profound
sense of civility is just another way to
save their elites like joe biden and dr
fauci from rightful deserved scorn here
now host of the liz wheeler show liz
wheeler and the daily caller editorial
director vince collins liz i think that
this is a situation where regardless of
what you feel
about
people expressing their opinion of the
president in this context i think that
you know the christmas call might not be
the necessary appropriate way to say it
the reaction from the media is that this
type of thing is a deep and dangerous uh
reality within america that ought to be
investigated and people ought to be
hunted down and exposed for expressing
their views even using words that can be
shared within polite society this was
not their attitude for the last five
years it seemed like when it came to
donald trump and the way that the media
treated him and certainly hollywood
treated him as well
right of course not i mean as you
mentioned they uh essentially applauded
kathy griffin when she held up a uh a
severed head or obviously an invented
not not a real severed head but the
severed head of president trump they
applauded this they thought this was
avant-garde they thought this was pithy
they thought this was cute the hypocrisy
is obvious here but the words of the
mainstream media i mean a quiet
insurrection to say let's go brandon to
the president to use joe biden's words
here come on man
as you said you can debate whether this
is a respectful thing to say to the
president of the united states but the
important thing ben is there's a reason
he felt like he needed to say it
directly to the president he felt like
he needed to say it because he feels
like he's being screwed over by the
biden administration and this is a this
is a view shared by a lot of the
american people they feel like they are
being left behind they feel like they're
being ignored and they feel like when
they voice their problems to their
elected officials that they're ignored
so yes you can argue that it's
disrespectful sure it probably is but it
also speaks to something
deeper among the american people
something important that they feel left
behind by their elected officials
you know vince there was something there
that
was said by the msnbc contributor uh
that i think is is pretty troubling this
this idea that you know uh the this
expression isn't
is not driven by
you know frustrations over the economy
or frustrations with the policies of the
bide administration that instead it
represents some kind of of creeping and
and virulent attitude toward the very
republic that we inhabit as citizens
i find that to be completely insulting
uh you know on its face but also it
seems to me part of their denial process
in saying that no one could actually
think this because their small business
has been ruined because the biden
economic policies have set them back
because they see what inflation is doing
in their communities and that to me is
just it's completely absurd
i had the same thought when i saw this
that guy saying that this was an act of
violence and this is like the steps
towards an insurrection it is a harmless
moment that this guy this guy was
actually in this relation this con the
conversation with the president of the
united states uh you know he actually
had a really nice conversation with him
i thought it was a little weird actually
the tone shift at the end he goes let's
go brandon uh i i think he just took his
opportunity because he wanted to impress
his buddies and his wife who doesn't
like joe biden and convey what you're
talking about that really that really
palpable frustration with the biden
administration but the idea that on
msnbc where they've created this fantasy
world where joe biden can do no wrong
where nobody would be upset about out of
control inflation nobody would be upset
about the way we got out of afghanistan
and let people die in the process nobody
would be upset about our collapsing
southern border no one would be upset
about the state of coven when we were
promised that this virus would shut down
it's not possible for someone to
criticize biden unless they're
captivated by a cult this is a media
distortion filter on display and they're
asking their audience to believe
something that is just completely untrue
it's disgraceful
but unfortunately it's become routine
you know vince i i think that uh and liz
i think that this is going to be
something that we're only going to
continue to see play out over the coming
year sadly
because as as things continue to get
worse for this administration as the
poll numbers get worse as midterm
elections approach they're going to have
to double down on this idea that anybody
who disputes what the white house is
doing anybody who disagrees with the
policy agenda that they actually have
some deeper malevolent motive as opposed
to just being americans who are awake to
what's going on in the country thank you
both for joining me tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else